SHIGERU MIYAGAWA: Particularly
at MIT, but in other places
teamwork is critical
to academic success.
One of the things
I tell freshmen,
is that I have been teaching
at MIT now for a long time.
And the students are
wonderful and very bright,
but what I've noticed
is that every year I
see two or three students really
stand out after they graduate,
and go on and do big things.
And I see this year
in and year out.
And all of the
students are wonderful.
They're academically gifted,
and they're highly motivated.
They have fire in their belly.
So what's the difference between
those two versus the rest?
Well, one day I figured it out.
The two who go on
to do big things
have learned to
work with others.
That's it.
There's nothing else
that I could see.
They have learned
to work not only
with people they share
interests, but also with people
that they don't necessarily
share interests.
That's the trick.
It's easy to work with
people who are like you.
It's harder to work with
people who are not like you.
But when you learn
to be able to work
across the spectrum
of people, then you
can basically tap their gifts.
That's what entrepreneurship
is actually.
And so this is a little
spiel that I give them
as part of why I
have in my syllabus,
a goal for this course is
to learn to work in teams.
I think I have that in
every class I teach,
doesn't matter what class.
A goal of this class is for
you to learn to work in teams.